[Music]
from director Tim Burton who never met a
studio title card he couldn't darken
okay this one didn't need much help
comes a filmography that spans four
different decades multiple genres and
10,000 pounds of white pancake makeup
[Music]
every Tim Burton movie put on your best
right suit and enter the mystical world
of Tim Burton which consists entirely of
the suburbs a lonely house sitting on a
hill or a lonely house on a hill
overlooking the suburbs and meet a Tim
Burton protagonist a pale loner cast out
by society and or their family looking
for acceptance and/or revenge
watch as they relive their tragic past
through flashbacks
I'm sorry I was having a flashback these
flashbacks happen often increasingly
attend fancy parties share the screen
with a horror icon or an actor playing a
horror icon fall in love with an
ethereal blonde I'll keep the plums in
here and finally overcome their terrible
parents he was a wonderful grandpa but
not such a great dad you know after that
night I didn't speak to my father again
for three years no parents deserve to
boil and hell's in a lost son five all
well dealing with an antagonist that's
probably wealthy overweight or both
you'll be sorry pee-wee Herman geez what
fed rich people do to this guy journey
into the mind of a director who's
constantly journeying into his own mind
can we do some kind of Freudian analysis
of you could figure out where this comes
from
good try as he uses tens of millions of
studio dollars to exercise his childhood
demons how strange were you was a child
from traumatizing memories at school
nobody seemed to really like me two
childhood fears I remember certain
clowns
we get a load of me no way to the least
surprising fact about Tim Burton
I love skeletons ok skeletons make sense
but what is it with Tim Burton and
mouths how about these
[Music]
[Applause]
I haven't seen bicuspids like these
[Music]
I've been lucky to make movies because I
feel like I get to work out all of my
psychological problems oh sure I have a
yard full of dead trees in the city
comes by but Tim Burton does it as art
so before you see his latest circus
themed creation relive the films of a
director who gave birth to the
big-screen bat directed one of the most
iconic comedies of the 80s one of the
strangest dramas of the 90s helped keep
the art of stop-motion animation alive
and also made these movies but it's
still best remembered for a film that he
didn't even direct yeah what's this
what's this it's not a Tim Burton movie
that's for sure probably starring
paleface Johnny Depp Lisa Marie Helena
bonham-carter
Lisa Marie and Helena Bonham Carter
awkward fear of commitment god I will
never marry you I would never marry you
graveyards old gnarled trees
contraptions
[Music]
my muscles and my bones couldn't keep up
with my body's ambition Siebert has a
present for you I'm spinning world
fairs and carnivals
[Music]
scary faces
a which Indian Trail to ever sunrise
she's yes most towns of a certain size
have a wig and models
[Music]
[Applause]
nice model every Tim Burton movie
eighteen movies and this guy still only
made one sequel where's Betelgeuse -
bigger fish bigger eyes miss Peregrine's
other home for peculiar children alison
wonderland - oh I mean that wouldn't
they
good call burden you do you man the
Sharks have frickin laser beams attached
to their heads by the power of Grayskull
I am Captain Planet my man a knock-knock
joke vegetables eat them to defeat them